I have a statement
here in yellow,
which, for the
sake of this video,
we will assume is true,
that eating spinach makes
you stronger.
And then after
this, in white, I've
written a bunch of
other statements.
And I want to figure out if
these are reasonable things
to say, given the assumption
that this first statement is
true, that eating spinach
makes you stronger.
And we could even
put it over here.
"Eating spinach
makes you stronger."
So let's read this
first sentence.
"If you eat spinach, then
you will get stronger."
So this is just really a
rephrasing of the first one.
This is really just
putting it in if-then form.
You have your "if" and
your "then," but it's
really saying the same thing.
If you eat spinach-- that's
the same thing as eating
the spinach-- then you
will become stronger,
then you will be stronger.
You get stronger.
So this is saying
the exact same thing.
I will say that if we assume
this first statement is true,
then the second statement
is definitely true.
Now, this third statement.
"If you don't eat spinach, then
you will not get stronger."
So this is interesting.
This is kind of assuming that
the only way to get stronger
is by eating spinach.
But that's not what that
first statement says.
That first statement
says eating spinach
is a way to get you stronger.
So if we think about
ways to get stronger,
there are other ways
to get stronger.
You could lift weights.
And maybe you don't want
to eat any spinach at all.
Maybe you eat eggs.
Who knows?
There's a million, you know--
maybe you have a-- drink milk.
Who knows what?
There are a lot of options
that will get you stronger.
Drink milk.
So eating spinach
is not the only way.
So if you don't eat
spinach, you still
might be able to get stronger.
They're not ruling out that
you can't get stronger.
So I would say, I would
not go with this statement
right over there.
Let me do it in red so
that I can mark it off.
This one is not
necessarily true.
You can get stronger other ways.
Now, if you eat spinach, you
will definitely get stronger,
if you believe that statement.
But you can get
stronger other ways.
So just by not eating spinach,
if you lift weights, eat eggs,
who knows what else, you
could still get stronger.
So we'll rule out
the second statement.
Now, this third statement.
"You are not stronger.
Therefore, you must not
have eaten spinach."
Now, this is where we really
have to put our logician hats.
And a logician is just
someone who has really,
really, really good logic.
"You are not stronger.
Therefore, you must not
have eaten spinach."
And we have to be very
careful to separate
our everyday
experience versus what
we're trying to
deduce logically.
So in our everyday
experience, I'm not stronger,
but maybe I did eat spinach.
And we'd say, hey, you know,
maybe sometimes spinach
doesn't make me stronger,
et cetera, et cetera.
But we have to remember, we're
assuming this first statement
is true.
We're assuming this first
statement is absolutely true.
Eating spinach
makes you stronger.
If you had eaten
spinach, by definition,
this first statement says
you will be stronger.
If you're not
stronger, then there's
no way that you
ate some spinach.
So this is actually true.
This is actually
true if we assume
this first statement is true.
Now, this last statement.
"You are stronger.
Therefore, you must
have eaten spinach."
Well, this goes
back to this idea.
That first statement didn't
say spinach is the only way
to get stronger, or the
second statement wasn't if
and only if you eat spinach,
then you'll get stronger.
There's other ways
to get stronger.
You could lift weights,
eat eggs, drink milk.
So this last statement--
you are stronger.
Therefore, you must
have eaten spinach--
isn't necessarily true.
You could have drank--
lifted weights,
or ate eggs, or
anything like that.
So I will rule this
one out, as well.
You cannot make this conclusion
given this first statement.